have been police raids this morning
across the West Midlands at targeting
county lines drugs in all there were 16
raids and 10 arrests let's get more
should we Becky
um has been with the West Midlands
police hi Becky what happened
yeah we were with police at five o'clock
this morning as those doors were
simultaneously bashed in at 16 different
houses across Birmingham solihull and
one in Essex as well over 200 police
involved they're all called to a
briefing at 4 30 this morning where they
were told who they were targeting
essentially told that they were
targeting a massive organized crime
group who are who were wanted in
connection with the supply of class A
drugs heroin and crack cocaine making
around 20 grand a day that organization
also wanted in connection with a kidnap
and Firearms offenses so this is the
culmination of months of effort and
police believe that by targeting these
addresses by making arrests they hope
that it will immediately significantly
reduce the supply of class A drugs in
this region county lines of course
involves the running of drugs from
usually cities like here in Birmingham
to other areas that involves gangs like
the The Gang That was the target of this
morning's raids the recruiting younger
more vulnerable people to run those
drugs so the police now working on
safeguarding as well as trying to gather
phones uh cash and drugs to bring these
people to Justice okay for now thank you